you know you look at at marie and
hank and i've always you know said this
i'm i'm
so proud and listen i love dean morris i
love him so much
um as he is a person as an actor but
i i love that we got to be part of that
story that was so beautiful
i mean that marriage with all you know
like and there's a lot of sadness
there you know i i think they
desperately wanted kids couldn't have
them
and um but they are so there for each
other
and and it's unconditional their love is
is beyond unconditional um and there's
you know such an amount of respect
which isn't really anywhere else in the
show
so it was you know it was lovely i
remember we did a photo shoot for the
pilot
for um you know just photos for
uh you know art for a deck for the set
and um it's
uh brian and anna dean and i and our
characters are on vacation it's supposed
to be like they're in mexico together
and i turned to dean and i hardly knew
him but i and i said
so we're drunk right like we're like we
all go out to dinner and we
always drink too much and just act like
fools
and um so we were just like making these
huge faces like we're just like the
people that are just
way too wasted at the party and um
and i i said to him that day i said i
don't know what's
gonna happen but i'm i've i'd sure
rather be part of this couple than
that couple i said i think i said ain't
no good going to come from that
you had no idea this was just the pilot
this was just the pilot
um but you know it was
every day we showed up and just wanted
to make the best show that we could make
and it was exciting to be part of that
i've heard you talk so highly about dean
a number of times now and also the
the love between him and marie is just
so palpable throughout the entire show
so what was it like talking through and
developing the moments of grief
marie experiences after she gets the
news because
that grief is is packed into just a few
tiny scenes
and you have to speak to an entire
series worth of material that we just
experienced with them
i tear up just when you say that i um
when i first got that script
and maura wally beckett wrote it and we
were
you know the cast was reading it and
then we were
emailing each other and i really put it
off
i put off reading it where he is killed
and i
and then i said you know like a child i
said
if i don't read it could it maybe not
happen
and so much of that was me as the actor
but also as the fan of the show
that world shifts if hank's not in it
not just for marie for everyone
for the entire story in just that world
the world is better
that world is better if he's there so
that was
in such a testament to the writers and
to dean that i
felt you know such a loss um and then
also i just
you know marie just loved him still does
so that was so hard for me
to do i still
haven't watched that whole episode like
just
can't do it
you